factions yeah on ice this report
initially comes from Lord Jason Shri FR
of Realm at Bloomberg who um yeah he
actually shout him I ran into him at
Summer Games Fest recently it's been a
long time since I've seen him but um
yeah um the article was why PlayStation
initially the first article was why
PlayStation fans are cheering CEO's
departure Jim Ryan oversaw the
successful launch of the PlayStation 5
his 4year tenure was also mared by some
flubs so basically the article goes on
to talk about the last two years Ryan is
over seeing a PlayStation shift towards
games and service a popular industry bu
buzzword referring to video games
usually multiplayer that can be
monetized over long periods of time has
become an uncomfortable pivot for some
of Sony Studios which have spent the
last decade building out teams of
experienced developers to make big
cinematic adventure games that are
played solo so they talked about
obviously the still Blockbusters in the
works uh Spider-Man 2 which we know is
coming in a few weeks um as far as the
single player Blockbusters and they said
um but Sony stable of game studios such
as Naughty Dog With The Last of Us andom
with Spider-Man and Gorilla Games
horizon horizon has also been working on
multiplayer service games with mixed
levels of success most have not been
revealed yet some have been cancelled or
overhauled such as the online game based
on the last of us and then that kind of
led us into the Kotaku article which was
kind of uh titled Last of Us Studio
naughty dog is cutting developers
PlayStation first party Studio behind
Uncharted and Last of Us is laying off
dozen of contractors so during the
course of this discuss of the
contractors being let off that's when
they kind of talked that's when we kind
of learned about the status of faction
so basically according to the article
layoffs were Comm I mean um sources tell
uh kataku that no severance is being
offered for those who were laid off the
contract y y y then it says uh despite
hit ratings for the HBO adaption of The
Last of Us a multiplayer spin-off for
the zombie shooter based on the first
game's factions mode has struggled in
development Bloomberg reported in June
that Sony had diverted resources away
from the project following a negative
internal review by Bungie the recently
acquired live service Powerhouse behind
Destiny 2 One Source now tells Kotaku
that the multiplayer game while not
completely cancelled is basically on ice
at this point so yeah this kind of set
off a a big you know Buzz as far as the
the status of um of factions which a lot
of people were really anticipated we
knew there was a Last of Us day recently
and there was no mention of it so um
before we get into our panel I think the
king had be free for this he has he has
starts so we going to mute and let you
hear what he has to say peace and
blessings hey what's going on
guys ah you see what I'm doing that's
why I couldn't be there I got to give
y'all all the support y'all need in
these trying times because we know what
October is is and October is a
horrifying month it's made even worse
with the be beginning of the
end I know a lot of y'all are saying
y'all Xbox dudes holding the line is
crazy and we held the line so it come
October the 13th Friday the
13th you'll be trying to hold the line
you got to go out and hold the line now
you see how I support
I'm supporting and I suggest that
everybody that loves PlayStation run out
and get a PlayStation VR2 go and support
I know it's not back comp Pat I know
it's not the best handheld I mean uh VR
on the
market but you guys got to go out there
and support because these passion
projects need to be funded in order to
generate Revenue there's no return on
investment that's why Jim left Jim is
gone and you guys are in
disarray we heard
factions like I said Is On Ice Ice Ice
Baby isn't that right
Dolph these dudes they be acting like
they number
one but it's all
cat but now on a serious note though
everybody got a chance to see what red f
did right yeah 60 frames per second what
you got to say now go back and fix your
face listen Phil dominous Maximus aelia
Spencer is not playing he's coming for
your head
pause so you know this Friday is the
beginning of the end and I want all my
PlayStation Brothers to hold the line
and go out and purchase go out and
support we got movies now with core I
know it was called Bravia before hey
PlayStation likes to do that they like
to say they got something and call it a
different name and make you think it's
something new it's not but you fall for
it anyway but hey hopefully next year we
can find out what's going to go down on
2024 cuz we have no idea at all Ro M
look kind of Bleak but we know when
Forza show up the generation start and
Forza just showed up
and this deal is about to close
Microsoft has been cleaning
house without even having this deal done
imagine what happens next stay tuned
where all the PlayStation dudes got to
hold the line cuz we held it and what
happened I told you if you don't believe
in them believe in me and remember I'm
98% right all the time well
I wish I could be there but I got to
watch the do be brothers so you guys
have fun and
enjoy
peace so
yeah there you have it uh thoughts of
the king you you've reached your goal
you we hit our we H our Target we held
the line for 300 likes and you got some
King boy you salute the king my brother
is he he forsake us for the Doobie
Brother today he couldn't get out of it
it forsaking us but uh yeah
rerunning what's happening you know what
I'm saying but U salute that clearly he
wanted to give the realm some thoughts
about the topics of the week so there
you have it but uh we got to get to our
esteemed guest Lord Paris um obviously
we've heard from the King but obviously
let's talk about this The Last of Us
factions you know the the potential news
that it could be on Ice what's your
thoughts about this whole situation
now look I understand that I might be
the Hydrox oh of of of iron Lords right
now trying to replace King okay you know
the GoBots
flavor yo
but he's a mess he's a hot mess that
that that's just a hot mess now he hit
on some points that are somewhat valid
in in his own special way the crazy part
is the crazy part is king would be
saying the most outrageous stuff but
there's still some
Realms I mean to his point about they've
not even closed the activis they're
saying 98% Paris 98% yeah 60% of the
time it works every time I know but
uh yeah they they're doing all this
without Activision so it they're not
depending on Activision to his point
fors is out now we got Starfield you see
a road map for what Xbox is going to
have in 24 M now I know he's very tongue
and- cheek about PlayStation but he is
correct that we have absolutely no idea
what PlayStation's coming with in in
2024 now what I will not agree with him
on is the whole Jim Ryan thing because I
feel you have to take it at face value I
mean he's been there 30 years he walked
into a great situation with PlayStation
he's leaving Playstation still in a in a
good place right
so we'll never know the truth on what it
is other than to take him at phas Value
so again I know he's tongue and cheek
with all that stuff but um it it will be
interesting to see where PlayStation
goes next into 2024 cuz we just we just
don't know I mean the only thing that we
know about right now is Wolverine yes
and that's not going to come next year
that'll probably be 2025 um to and I was
looking at the chat too uh just like
with Bungie and this whole Last of Us
factions thing yeah good if if Bungie
came in and and and as a fellow Destiny
head you know what I mean if Bungie came
in and looked at that game and said hey
this is not going to keep long-term
engagement you're not going to be
financially viable with this game put it
on ice then for exactly what they're
doing some of these other projects that
they're talking about if those have been
reworked or cancelled then good let's
not just throw a bunch of stuff at the
wall and see what sticks because all
it's because we we're seeing where live
service games are right now anyways
really the only two that have remained
viable are fortnite which keeps evolving
and and Destiny yeah that's it I mean
the division is starting to make a
little bit of a comeback but we've seen
so many others die on the vine very
quickly preach that I would if I want
the last V factions to be honest with
you but I want them to do it right right
so if it's not going to be successful
then delay it I mean there it's not 100%
canceled but clearly they need to go
back in the lab and figure out what
they're doing but again to to to King's
tongue and
point what's coming in
2024 yeah I I'm dying to know or is
PlayStation
gonna have their XBox 2022 moment
because that's what it sounds like
remember Xbox they had they had the
delay Starfield and redfall and all we
got was penam right and and and grounded
1.0 that's all we got yeah is that's is
that what's about to happen with
PlayStation first party one thing that
we don't really take in account is you
know we say what's coming out 2024 2025
and on it's like but maybe they have
been showing us like the majority of the
games that were in development during
the pandemic can stuff their games as
service games uh you know maybe that's
what they have in in the talk for a
little bit you know obviously we'll see
the Wolverine I assume ghost of shishima
is in development too the sequel to that
game you know these games are coming but
I I said from the start it's like you
know people wanted to not give Microsoft
a little bit of leeway because of like
the pandemic and to a point I agree but
at the same time it's like I I'm I truly
believe that Sony just had more games
closer to the Finish goal before the
pandemic
so they had a little bit of hiccups but
they were able to push those games to
the Finish go the Finish Line I think
what you're seeing
now is what Microsoft was dealing with
back then because the games that was
close to the Finish Line they were able
to push those in because they they were
doing the final touches of the game but
the games that was in full-blown
development during the pandemic like a
lot of Microsoft games were at that time
now you're seeing what these games is
what Sony was having issues with the
pandemic I guess I guess want to get
back to to Paris for a second um in
reference to what he said about
obviously you know the the quality of
the game and and I guess Bungie being in
there for oversight right to to kind of
review and see you know what where it
was at like ultimately I guess my
question is who do you think Sony made
if this report to be true we know
Jason's reporting tend to be strong like
do you think Sony ultimately makes the
call to fully cancel do you think
there's any chance of Resurgence or come
again because I've seen some push back
of people say Hey you know well just
they should have just released it anyway
we we still want to see what that
version is and that's okay break break
that down no I that I definitely
disagree if it's not going to live up to
a certain standard like when you think
of The Last of Us you're thinking of a
high quality quality AAA experience
right that pushing that into factions
into a multiplayer component you I don't
think it's going to go let me start this
way okay it's going to come out
eventually but clearly whatever it was
it needs way more time so that's why
you're you're seeing it go back in the
lab because that IP is just way too
valuable to to not put something like
that out so I just think yeah they're
going to go back rework it figure out
the the whole point of life service
games is to get you in the door look the
first hit's free you already know bring
them in and then have you so engaged
that you willingly want to buy these
micr and Jacks and keep playing the game
so if that's what they need to do if
that's what they need to figure out then
that's what they'll do look it may not
come till PlayStation 6 but that's okay
I still think it happens the fact that
you already have part one you already
have part two those are critically
acclaimed great games the TV show is
critically acclaimed yes that IP has
Brand awareness now outside of gaming so
absolutely you want to have something
else that's going to pull people in
besides the first two games we know any
last of us three is for sure PlayStation
6 you know it's not going to Happ
anytime soon so if they need a few more
years to rework this and figure out what
you know to do it the right way then
that's what they're going to do that
just that just makes sense to me they
would it would not be viable in my
opinion to just completely cancel Last
of Us factions because I do think
there's a market for it clearly there
are people as as you're saying that want
to play it that want to see it but let's
just make sure we do it right let's not
have it come out we're excited for a
month or two and then it's just goes
away CU nobody's playing it anymore Noir
fair enough fair enough addict wouldn't
finish your bars on on the whole
situation in reference to you know
obviously the the news that the game
Last of Us factions is on
Ice um I'm a little half and half with
Paris um I do think that they are
looking at the The Last of Us it wasn't
cancelled uh could be just a variety of
things where they're like we don't want
to come out and announce a game that's
been cancelled or it could be one of
those things where it's like we got to
restructure we got to figure out you
know what exactly you know maybe Bungie
will work with them more on the on the
you know the uh the monetization part
because I think that's the true thing is
like the monetization because last was
factions BG maybe they're trying to
casualized game because if you go in
there right now factions factions is not
an easy multiplayer by any means and it
you know it could be a variety of that I
personally feel like if they don't go
back and rework I agree with pairs that
won't be cancelled I think they'll
restructure it and add it on to The Last
of Us Part Two remake or last of us
three as a factions to that game before
they just cancel it entire so you think
they'll go away from the stand alone I'm
just want to be clear it just depends if
they're able to find a middle ground
with Bungie and find out a way to
monetize the game because I don't think
that Sony's just going to continue to
throw uh more and more money at it I do
think there is an end point and clearly
you know you you see all the the the
contract workers got laid off yeah you
saw uh you know they they they started
they've already started funling less
money into it it reported happened in
June now you got reports that's being on
Ice to me that's either we need to find
out what we truly want to do with this
or do we want to take the work we've
already done now restructure it and put
it with the Last of Us Part Two remake
no fair enough fair enough Lord Sol Last
of Us factions rumors on on ice what are
your thoughts on
this I really do feel like that product
is mostly finished uh to adct point I
think it it the thing is how do we
package this how do we sell this how do
we you know how is it do we turn it into
a free topl thing do we sell this as a
$70 thing I I do I do think it's the
monetization and I think I think a lot
of you know the fact that the the person
that they brought over from um from epic
to work on that LE yes is perhaps a
little bit telling
right that you know maybe there was kind
of butting of heads there in terms of
how to monetize this and just to be
clear not to cut you that was the person
from every who dealt with fortnite's
monetization yes okay got it so you know
somebody who's kind of an expert in how
to how to make something turn something
into a living breathing sort of thing
that can survive for for a long time um
but it goes back to the point that I
argued when we first heard about this a
couple of months back where it was like
why does it need to be that um and and
again maybe that's just me being
idealistic because at the moment you
turn that from a a you know from a mode
in Last of Us Part Two into its own game
it obviously has to expand to something
bigger and grander right um you know a
$70 product so to speak so um but what I
always assumed it was it was something
that was going to be a little more
cinematic narrative sort of Base but it
gave you that sort of that multiplay
player sort of what you what you got
from factions originally in the in the
original game just expanded upon and
what maybe some storytelling around it
that kind of gives you insight into the
world of the last of us as opposed to
these characters that you know of
already in that World um so that's my
impression of what that was um and then
you have Bungie come in and again this
is us assuming you know the amount of
power that Bungie has within Sony to say
no yes no um but if there is a thing
where it's like hey Bungie's thinking
about where these games need to be and
what kind of products they need to be is
this living ongoing thing we have to
figure out a way for people to to be to
for this game to be sticky right for for
for two three four years whatever the
case may be real quick S I don't think
Bungie has the power to go in there and
you know just shut stuff down oh no not
say like shut it down but their their
suggestions hold a lot of weight yeah I
think it it's it's like that you know
they would they showed the report and
they're okay what you mean as report
then they went back to to naughty dog
with factions I was like this is what
Naughty Dog thinks of this mod how do
you expect how debate it you know it's
like it's like how do you expect to you
know go against the grain that n that
that Bungie here has and I don't think
naughty dog passed the uh they didn't
pass the checks man they yeah when it
come when it comes to creating that type
of game that Bungie is known for now um
yeah I just think there's just sort of
butting up heads of how they sell this
game how they allow this game to live
and I just sort of think that you know
Bungie's design ethos was we're going to
give you this cool multiplayer we we're
going to wrap it up into a a more sort
of pristine kind of quadruple a product
that you sort of expect from Bungie with
some story with a little more context
for the world of The Last of Us and do
it that way but not necessarily
expecting people you know the people who
gravitate to it and love it are going to
play it for a long time but beyond that
maybe not create uh systems within the
game which kind of you know the cared on
the stick thing that you have with with
with Destiny and other sort of uh live
service games where it's like okay what
do we do to bring them back week over
week engag
yeah I'm I'm sorry I I don't know how to
I don't know how to interject on please
please just do just do we we jump in
that's we jump in just jump in brother
yeah we we jump in but I'm the only one
that gets repercussions for it so well
you do you do it the most you do it the
most we let you Ro Contin no but
ironically enough as as we're talking
about this I'm thinking there's another
game in company that's doing the same
exact thing but not getting the
publicity because it's all rumor and
speculation on this project even
existing but 343 and and Halo and Tanaka
or Tatanka or whatever TKA yes I mean
think about it 343 just went through a
major restructuring leadership
contractors got laid off we obviously
don't know with certain Infinity of of
any layoffs or restructuring that may
potentially happen with them but again
if you go by R in speculation Jess
Cordon that game has evolved into
something a lot bigger than what they
originally planned because remember it
was just supposed to be an add-on to
Halo infinite where now it sounds like
it's going to be its own Standalone
thing so maybe this is similarly what's
happening with factions where we had an
idea for it we realized this isn't going
to have a long tale let's restructure it
and turn it into something bigger and to
point maybe it does want maybe it's not
free to play maybe it becomes a $70
purchase that has you know DLC and
microtransactions attached to it because
now it has its own story and its own
thing that makes it stand out that no
it's not the last of us three but it's
in The Last of Us universe and there's
like a co-op or multiplayer component to
it so I I get you know these articles
come out and and we see it for what it
is like oh wow it's on Ice contractors
got laid off this isn't good but maybe
there is a long-term plan with this
where look we need to scale it back for
now we need to replan and then when
we're ready to go back into full
production we can rehire because it's
contractors laying off weren't laying
off like Naughty Dog
employees maybe now we can hire some
more contractors and go back into full
production on this in another year to 18
months who knows yeah that that's what
makes sense right that the fact that the
contractors if you if you're putting it
on ice the contractors don't have
anything to do because they're the guys
right so um why they figure figure out
what they're going to do with this um
yeah it doesn't make sense that they'd
be there but I really do I hope it comes
out I hope that they by the time it
comes out that you know 50% of it isn't
on the cing room floor right I hope that
we do get this really I hope that the
vision that they have for it is able to
come out as intact as possible um and
maybe maybe that's being idealistic
maybe the you know the the their design
ethos coupled with making a a
service-based game just doesn't mesh I
don't know yeah um but I really do hope
that that doesn't mean this game just
never sees a lie to day because that
would suck and again it's a lot of time
sunk into something that's ultimately
not coming out for a studio that only
drops maybe one or two games per
generation as it is so you know if this
is if this ends up just going away
that's years sunk into something that's
not happening so um yeah that sucks no
well said I agree with both what
everyone's saying this this is tough
because um you know on one hand and I
you know I saw Jason's article I respect
the PIV I know a lot of people give Jim
Ryan a lot of you know grief for for
some of the moves and some of the things
you said I get it but as far as to Pivot
the live service I always felt soy
needed to do this you know to kind of
stay vial that's how the industry is
changing so but live service is hard you
know it's it's very difficult you have
to you know the monetization model to
get people coming back and then the
thing I also want to kind of not dispel
but I'm seeing this talk that it's like
because this is nobody doing right this
is the great Naughty Dog how can
anything they put out not be quality
there is a distinct difference between
you know making what I consider player
games as a service hash just one which
they are arguably one of the Masters of
right then to make a viable multiplayer
game that is consistent and I agree with
Paris in the sense that you know there's
a quality bar there right and and and
also not just a quality it has to be an
engagement bar and To Me the Way it was
being treated when we first heard of it
we like okay where is it should be
attached to the last of us you know
remake or whatever and then we heard
okay no it's going to get a standalone
game so at that point you thinking it's
more robust it's going to you know have
more features and things of that nature
and then obviously we get the report so
the way I look at it is it's either two
things happen it's either in my opinion
you know obviously Bungie part of the
reason why they were acquired was they
are going to have their expertise leaned
on for PlayStation game studios during
this pivot so when that happens to me
it's like okay check this out it's
either a the game is fundamentally not
good at a gameplay loop at its core
right and then Sony maybe shuts down
cuts his losses and obviously QA let go
or whatever right and we know that they
have a very high quality bar at s from
from a Metacritic standpoint that's one
possibility I'm thinking another one is
that it is a solid multiplayer game it's
a good multiplayer game but maybe maybe
not a good live service game not a game
like s you said sticky retain you know
engagement getting people to come back
and I kind of I kind of think of in a
way Halo infinite at launch we could say
what we want the core game was fun
amazing it was fun it was amaz like the
it was so good as far as just the the
minute to- minute gameplay and
engagement but what we started to learn
as he went on right the monetization
model wasn't there I mean the um you
know the live service model wasn't there
the content to make you keep coming back
the Skins the events it was kind of bare
bones and then it started to suffer now
now they've come back but to Sony point
maybe they don't want to wait you know
two years three years to go through any
type of growing pains and lose on
investment so the other thing we got to
look at is you know we're in a world of
free to play right and I think Paris you
touched on the monetization model right
what what kind of works do we make it a
$70 game Standalone right but then maybe
they say hey in a world where for it's
free right in a world where a lot of
these games are free to play you know
would have to be free to play right do
we get that stickiness and then you know
it's one of those things and I think I
had this conversation with Rand and I
was just like in my opinion cuz I play
Live service I play Destiny all you know
all stuff all the time in my opinion
it's it's kind of hard to not do free to
play and on multiple platforms cuz we
know like for example they've been with
the PC ports it's been kind of like one
year later son right so the the argument
is can you drop a $70 game and limited a
live service game to just PlayStation
they can't no that's I agree I agree I
agree another that wall Garden thing is
not going to work with it doesn't work
for life so in my opinion I'm with you s
like you've got to get the most players
the most engagement so you kind of have
to break that
rule and and say hey it's PC also day
one right and you you got to have a good
model to make people come back and the
last thing I'll say is just that look
obviously I'm a huge fan of bunch I saw
some some talk going on Paris I was I in
my feelings man they was like yo they
how dare these dudes they they should
have just dropped them I don't like the
power they got over there and look I get
it but let's be respectful this is the
creator of Halo the creator of Destiny
regardless of how you feel about Destiny
you can't knock the engagement and the
LA longevity what is it almost what is
it 2014 well they're they're about to
hit their 10e plan they about final
shape talk about 10 years in the game
we've been through all the destiny
Killers you know what I'm saying the
anthems division one division two I
can't playing two years of my life and
they doing 10 10 years of playing like
Coast to playing this game so again we
take the emotion out of it hey they've
had their ups they had I'm not going to
say the game's perfect they've had their
ups they had their down but you cannot
deny the long as of I look right now I
think it was like top 10 or just outside
the top 10 right now during all the the
the crazy PR stuff that's going on bu
right now and yeah I think what makes
them you
know another thing that people don't
acknowledge is the fact that what makes
them so good at what they do also is the
extent of their failures as well because
absolutely when you look at this this
this model that they that they sort of I
won't say perfected right but that they
really have a handle on it's almost like
the the the valleys are planned for like
you know hey we're going to suck right
here but we're going to bring it back up
and then we're going to go back down and
it and it's this undulating thing that
you almost expect as part of the process
so when they look at you can't say
Bungie has just had crazy success in
this space without understanding how to
get there and just you sometimes
somebody has success from the jump and
they never fall and they don't see what
it takes to to kind of build themselves
up to a certain level or or or sort of
deal with adversity they've dealt with
adversity at every turn so when they
look at a faction and say and for me
like I said I'm I'm of the mind it maybe
it doesn't have to be this game that
lives for 10 years yeah I'm cool with it
being something that I mean but Sony Jim
Ryan went 10 live service games correct
and that's that's another question to
ask right does whoever come in comes in
do they follow that Mantra or do they
say hey we I don't need this particular
game to be that
um and and kind of roll that back right
because I do feel it is a Jim Bryan sort
of Mantra where it was like hey we need
these to be this right and we at least
see what we have if we put this type of
game out there so yeah I I think what
makes Bungie so good at what they do and
the fact that you know so this push back
you're getting like oh they shouldn't
have this P the fact of the matter is
they understand the highs and they
understand the lows right so there's
nobody body better to have brought in to
be like hey this works this doesn't work
this work this doesn't work because they
understand the entire spectrum of it is
what I would say no absolutely and I I
agree you know what I'm saying it's
definitely been trial by fire and and at
the end of the day you know they've been
able to make the successful pivots
whether it's self-imposed or that you
know mean when during you know Destiny's
run to be able to do a console live
service game and continue to have the
engagement they have you cannot deny the
engagement but I last what I wanted to
say which is that um what I do find
interesting is I want to know what you
guys think about it in reference to the
Jason sh report saying that his inside
sources are saying that PlayStation
Studios have an
uncomfortability with the pivot some of
them with the pivot to live service and
that as traditional single player game
makers now with this new edict from up
top that we're going to need you when
you see Sony Santa Monica's name and you
hear Naughty Dogs name and you know some
of these Studios these traditional
amazing games now having to be make this
style of game what do you feel about an
uncomfortable pivot like do you think
that that this could cause unrest
because developers want to do what they
want to do or they're just in a the the
the Pains of a transition like what do
you think Paris I'm just curious okay so
you want to get me in trouble yes I'm
I'm I'm trying to get me in trouble I
see what just happen I got bamboo
on got gotta get you make it those tough
questions man here's what here's what
could happen I and it's ironic because
you didn't mention gorilla and all of
that of of all their major Studios
gorilla would probably be the most
comfortable because with their Kill Zone
Legacy so they have multiplayer
experience but that's the exact point
you're asking Studios that traditionally
have not done multiplayer components to
now start doing not only multiplayer but
a full unmonetized life service
component as well so there there is
going to be unrest with that there is
going to be uneasiness with that and
here's where I'm going to get in trouble
let's go What will What potentially
could happen is you see top talent leave
and go elsewhere that's what could
happen especially if hey I don't want to
make multiplayer games I like making I
don't know God of War or whatever right
why are you trying to make me make God
of War the multiplayer game I don't want
to do that I'm gonna go somewhere else
where I can continue to make the things
that I want to make since we're talking
Bungie and all that why do you think
Bungie if you go back and look through
their history left Xbox in the first
place they didn't want to be the Halo
Studio they wanted to start doing other
all of a sudden these studios are being
made to do things they don't want to do
you're going to see people that have the
skill set and the talent to go I didn't
sign up for this I'm out of here very
I'm not saying it's gonna look look try
try not to get in too much trouble I'm
not saying it's gonna happen right I'm
just saying that opens up the
possibility for it to happen so we'll
see no I think that's fair solve adct
with your thoughts on that real quick
before you move
on SOL can go first there's noise in the
back no you good um yeah I do think see
if if there was a if there's a pivot
within Sony first party that is that
black and
white that's just stupid I mean that's
just stupid now now you're telling
people that have been making X type of
game for decades you're going to Pivot
to this and you're GNA have to learn how
to you're gonna have to figure this out
right and that's the part that kind of
doesn't sit well with me I mean they
they they made all these other smaller
purchases specifically I thought to to
focus on that sort of stuff right the
names of the studios Escape me right now
but they have a bunch of new
acquisitions that kind of I felt fire
fire Sprite and things of that nature
that that I felt were sort of working on
those types of games Jade Raymond Studio
things of that nature right so my
thinking was okay we're going to bring
in these Studios to make these type of
games with you know Bungie sort of
overseeing everything in addition to
whatever bung's making right CU Bungie's
next game is obviously going to be on
all platforms but obviously it's going
to have that PlayStation sort of stamp
of approval on it right
um and I figured the the studios that
were making you know the the single
player just just ones or whatever were
going to be left alone if that is a
mandate a true mandate from within then
you're not reading you're not reading
the last 10 15 years of the industry and
what happened when you tried to tack on
multiplayer game gameplay to games that
had no business having it you know yeah
attacking on multiplayer to Bioshock uh
two or something like that like just to
be clear I just want to interrupt for
one second so the report says that even
though single player Blockbusters are
still in the work Sony stable game
studios Naughty Dog Insomniac Gorilla
Games have also been working on see it
appears to be separate multiplayer I
just want to be clear like not
necessarily add-on but that's where some
of the uncomfortability it's like they
they're being say being told but the
rumor that they that they also have to
work on these separate multiplayer games
as opposed to like an add-on game listen
nobody likes to take a part of their
team team and and you know and and sort
of section them off to do something
different when you're working on a big
project if that is the case I feel for
them because again I I get that at the
same time if it is not invading the
actual single player product that
they're working on apart from taking
away resources but if if it the Mandate
isn't you know uh fit this into you know
your next single player uh narrative
Adventure I'm fine with it um again
things will play out the way will play
out and if the quality of the of that
game suffers as a result of trying to
make this multiplayer thing it'll you
know it'll be evident and hopefully
that'll change Minds internally um but
yeah to me that I get it and to paris's
point the industry well now you know
there was a while while that you know
the the the the the eating was good out
there you could leave and you were going
to get you could leave just for the sake
of leaving and and if you had the
credentials you were going to get a
pretty nice package wherever you're
going things have kind of shifted a
little bit where it's you know you you
have to worry a little bit about
stability um but yeah at the end of the
day if you're being forced to do
something that you don't have expertise
in that you don't want to do these guys
are going to up and leave and they're
going to start migrating to other places
and there you know again you have a you
have a new Nintendo console on the
horizon and I'm sure they'd love to have
devs you know working on that you have
Xbox always on the on the
Lurch for for devs um
especially you know again trying to sort
of fill out you know the game pass
catalog and stuff like that you will see
there will be places for these types of
devs to go yeah so again that type of
mandate to me no matter how you
implement it feels sucky and weird um
but again I get it so it it it's going
to be interesting to see whomever comes
in if some of this stuff gets rolled
back and and not not because last week I
said hey whatever's been whatever's been
put into
play it the ball is rolling right I
would say you you mostly have to see
that through and then see and then pivot
from there if it if it really fails
misera um but at the same time I think
there are certain things again I I'm
sure with new management coming in you
have the the heads of these Studios
talking to them like hey there's certain
things that we were asked to do that
we're not super comfortable with is
there something that we could do to sort
of roll some of this back you know not
necessarily you know dip a toe in but
not you know things of that nature so
you know we'll see how that plays out
but uh yeah anytime it's never a good
thing when you're asked to do something
that you're not comfortable doing or
have not done before it's never panned
out well I think even when we look at
the the the the gorilla example these
guys took years to Pivot to this other
thing right in the background
um yeah I don't even know that the devs
that made kills though a a large part
portion of them I don't know how many of
them are still at gorilla right they
that's true that's a good point those
guys could have migrated away to
someplace else to make fpss right so I
don't know I I really don't know what
this what this does but um if it if it
you
seem if that is the case it's not it's
not good because the results have never
been good history will tell you that the
results of of of doing things like this
have never been good so no doubt ad let
me get your thoughts it quickly because
I got to get I want to ask Paris one
last question because I know he's got to
go soon but addict your thoughts on on
that whole last part portion we were
talking about I mean if if you know
they're truly being forced to make a
game like that I agree with Sol 100% you
know even if it's just a small portion
of the studio uh they're going to need
leads to some degree uh because I I I
would assume they wouldn't put nothing
but you know uh newcomers that's in the
industry in here I assume that there are
some prominent members of their studio
in this so I think it's just one of
those things where it's
like you bought
Studios to make these games
if it is true that other like their core
Studios the people that make the single
player games and they're kind of being
pushed in this direction as well then
why did you buy those other Studios you
know it's like the the PC portion you
know they usually parked her up with the
studio they're making they were bought
for the PC ports and they've been doing
that yeah n so you know to me bring it
you want like dedicated multiplayer
teams so to speak Studio now if to me if
it would make more sense to have okay
you know we tried this it didn't work
let's let's co-develop some you know
let's have uh this multiplayer Studio
that we bought that has been nurtured
that's where reason Microsoft tries to
keep things in the same willhouse
because for the most part if they do
decide to continue on that franchise
they want people that know what they're
doing in that type of genre know what
they're doing have experience in there
you know a lot of developers are very
versatile but certain jobs require an
expert